auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge ja das sind die neuen chefs und
an chef braucht noch einen schlüssel
habe ich den behinderten sind sicher wir
zuschüsse in der positiven lohn ja wir
also vielen dank wie man sie aber wir
kommen als das weiß das ist so die
familie am rieder ist in ihrer
kanadischen heimat angekommen
für die kinder hat die schule bereits
begonnen und die eltern haben ihr modell
übernommen
susanne und rudi althaus wollen in
uruguay eine ferien lodge baum für ihren
traum haben sie ihr heim im emmental
aufgegeben
die ist bereits abgereist zusammen folgt
in vier monaten
der hut kommt mit die kinder kommen nach
die eltern kunst haben sie verabschiedet
ihre neue existenz ein ähnliches wagen
an der nordsee
[Musik]
in kanada ist zumindest bei den kindern
der alma dass der alltag eingekehrt
oder software und robin fahren ganz
kanadisch mit dem bus zur schule
ein außergewöhnlicher tag hingegen ist
heute für die eltern angebrochen
vier monate war das velmore hotel an der
mainstreet und hat im august geschlossen
jetzt eröffnen sie das leben als
hoteliers in kanada kann beginnen
18 zimmer und ein großzügiger
aufenthaltsraum warten auf gäste
[Musik]
die tourismussaison in nova scotia
beginnt im mai josef hat nur noch zeit
für die nötigsten reparaturarbeiten noch
lange ist nicht alles so wie es gerne
hätte die störe zur sache
das sieht mir doch einfach 100 mal am
kommenden montag das tageslicht und
barriere dann das nicht so gern zur
sache was das theater zu machen hat ja
komitee mit der vorstellung dass man
scanner habe ihr die haare und aber
vielleicht ist das problem wenn ich noch
und ich muss mich da vielleicht damit
abfindet osten bei uns nicht so super
faktisch wieder schwitzen verliert er
könnte aber das ist okay das flugzeug
und zeigen sie mir da immer wieder ein
vorteil gegenüber der schweiz ist albers
haben hier eine angestellte
[Musik]
ein glücksfall so trost und schon weiß
gott glauben musste
während für die zimmer gesorgt ist macht
das buchungssystem es funktioniert nicht
[Musik]
auf der südlichen halbkugel amerikas in
uruguay beginnt in der april der herbst
am frühen morgen landen ruhe die und
sein kollege markus in der hauptstadt
montevideo
[Musik]
der schweizer hat eine beraterin
engagiert die deutsche alex sie hatte
ein großes netzwerk
[Musik]
wir waren die letzten entstehen sollen
sie stehen in der schweiz
das kennen wir
bei den apps
[Musik]
der 53-jährige ist die metropole weit
hinter sich
er wandert ins ländliche wobei in die
pampa aus nach gut zweieinhalb stunden
fahrt erreichen sie das neue zuhause des
emmentalers die kleinstadt colonia del
sacramento
[Musik]
für die ersten wochen hat ruhe die an
der avenida general flores ein zimmer
bei senioren es gemietet
nach meiner mannschaft der burg liegt an
den herdplatten brauchst dann können sie
das noch kaufen so musste gucken oder du
kommst ja was und masseur kaufen würden
wir uns gut ist perfekt
[Musik]
ja hat durch das internet
da susan bei den ersten arbeiten nur
wenig helfen könnte ist sie in der
schweiz geblieben um weiterhin geld für
ihr projekt zu verdienen
[Musik]
an der nordseeküste in deutschland sind
prix geht unser star kunst gemeinsam
unterwegs
ihre geschäftsgrundlage der imbisswagen
steht bereit nun geht es um die details
[Musik]
hoffentlich
der imbisswagen bekommt einen neuen
namen und ein eigens entworfenes logo
oben
die beschriftung
namen nennt und und plötzlich ist eine
der größten in beeskow mit europa mit
mettwurst und redet eigentlich lieber
sanft zuerkennt und am schluss ist das
eigentlich so entstanden also das war
sie ihre familie man das eigentlich so
beschlossen und und auch die arbeits
hemmten sollen wurst und robbie
schmücken
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
und auf geht's die künftigen
grillmeister haben noch einiges auf
ihrer tendenz liste
in peter mosch ist es abend geworden
[Musik]
nur das problem mit dem buchungssystem
haben die einmal das noch immer nicht
lösen können
[Musik]
beatrice sucht rat bei dem früheren
besitzer des bootes
[Musik]
er hat irgendwie hat das nur ist die e
mail adresse des e mail abruf
unternehmen in professioneller support
vermurkst das heißt die e mails auf die
idee gehabt internet
[Musik]
vorbesitzer team ist ein hilfsbereiter
mensch er will das problem sofort lösen
dass sämtliche buchungsanfragen noch
immer über teams handy laufen muss sich
schleunigst ändern team verspricht das
problem zu beheben
[Musik]
doch kaum haben die vorbesitzer des
motel verlassen haben die albers ein
neues problem der drucker
[Musik]
trotz langer reise noch am tag der
ankunft will die seinem kollegen markus
das grundstück zeigen
das grundstück liegt zehn autominuten
von colonia del sacramento entfernt das
grundstück fünf hektar groß ist das
stück knapp zwei franken kostete der
quadratmeter bauland
wer sich dort verglichen
in dieser idylle wollen ruhe die un
susan eine passage bauen eine ferien
lodge mit fünf häuschen einem restaurant
und tool durch die ersten probleme mit
dem baumeister sind schon da jetzt so
gut wie marvin ist man beim reden die er
heimlich seinen ja auch noch nicht
erklärte der christdemokrat koloss
gewinn
[Musik]
noch in gewohnter umgebung arbeitet
susanne althaus sie ist pflegefachfrau
auf der onkologie abteilung des berner
inselspitals
die 52-jährige ist die älteste und
erfahrenste im team
die patienten brauchen ihre volle
aufmerksamkeit
für die jungen pflegefachfrauen ist
susan mehr als nur eine kollegin
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
an der nordsee arbeitet das ehepaar kunz
ihrer to-do-liste ab der erste besuch
bei einem us lieferanten stimmt sascha
zuversichtlich dass sie ein paar schäden
zwei tagen habe
im sommer läuft und
viel war buche
also im grunde kaum zu früher
loszufahren jede zweite bis dritte tag
und ich weiß nicht ob ein gast ermittelt
obwohl stinke
also das sind doch was sind 20 minuten
eimer
[Musik]
würste allein machen noch keinen grill
imbiss wichtigste beilage sinn von fritz
auch an dieser hat es ehepaar hohe
ansprüche
ja er ist kurz und ich wollte sie die
reine frage also für und sie zum
beispiel pommes frische frische pommes
auch nur tiefgekühlt ja okay gut da
haben sie mir sagen geholfen
danke schön schöner abend ein frühchen
also nicht gekühlt sondern frische die
geschmacklich einfach besser sind aber
ich gar nicht so einfach den lieferanten
kelvin ihr ältester sohn will zu seinen
eltern nach deutschland ziehen
der gelernte elektriker hilft schon mal
bei der strom installation
[Musik]
auch kevin soll in zukunft mit seinen
eltern hinter dem grill stehen
im oberen stock des wohnhauses richtet
sich der 19 jährige eine eigene kleine
wohnung ein
ästhetik sonst okay das ist eine sehr
wichtig vor allem dann wenn sie wollte
ende juli anfang august zu materie und
verdammt natürliche und die person und
dem wunsch einfach sagt street sich so
schön lange cdu
kaum funktioniert das buchungssystem
stehen erste gäste vor dem hotel bereit
sind
die reservierung hat geklappt nun muss
das paar nur noch die bestätigung
unterschreiben
doch genau diese kann josef im system
nicht finden
[Musik]
nicht mehr schub an der emmer am rio de
la plata in colonia del sacramento der
ältesten stadt uruguays ist rudis neues
zuhause
550 dollar kostet das thema monatlich
bei senioren
das hat sich herumgesprochen
heute trifft ruhe die seinen künftigen
baumeister maurice ihren alex die
beraterin hatte das grundstück
vermittelt heute ist sie nur zum
dolmetschen mit dabei zur besprechung
ist auch architekten wie männer bekommen
[Gelächter]
noch einmal wollen sie die baupläne
durchgehend änderungen vornehmen und
missverständnisse aus der welt schaffen
als gelernter baustelle mit jahrelanger
erfahrung hat ruhe die klare
vorstellungen
macht aus das haben wir nicht letzter zu
beraten
auch mario ist ein erfahrener berufsmann
bald steht einem akzeptablen
kostenvoranschlag nichts mehr im wege
oder willst du noch fünf
kostenvoranschläge von anderen firmen
haben nein nein
[Musik]
außerdem werden
was
[Musik]
auch am wasser liegt der künftiger
arbeitsplatz der familie kurz auf der
domplatte 1 stehen mehrere in wiesbaden
hier gibt es rollmöpse matthäus
krabbenbrötchen und crêpes zu kaufen
würstchen und frikadellen werden das
exklusive angebot von brigit und sascha
sein
[Musik]
der wagen der von nun an die fünfköpfige
familie ernähren soll ist nicht
irgendein kerl warten
sein ehemaliger besitzer pommes peter
ist eine lokale größe mit einem festakt
will der deutsche heute den schweizern
den wagen übergeben
nach 25 jahren schuften wollen pommes
peter und seine frau kürzer treten und
haben einen ihrer wagen nun verkauft
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
muss doch
geheim
quito
klar
ja ich wusste gar nicht dass hier so
viele menschen unseren abschied
miterleben möchten dafür möchten wir uns
bei euch recht herzlich bedanken möchten
unseren betrieb abgeben an die familie
kunz aus der schweiz darf ich euch mal
davon lassen die neue chefs und ein chef
braucht auch einen schlüssel wie man sie
aber wir kommen als der schweiz das ist
so wünsche ich natürlich der familie
auch weiterhin alles gute
wir werden ja weitermachen am nächsten
freitag werden wir eröffnen um 12 uhr
geht es dann los für uns
der oktober und dann schauen wir dann
wieder weiter ich bedanke mich schon
jetzt voraus und wünsche ihnen noch
einen schönen tag
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hatte
ja
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wir haben gut davon gelebt natürlich wir
haben jedes jahr einen schönen urlaub
uns dafür gegönnt
dafür haben wir aber links auch sieben
tage in der woche gearbeitet
und immer schön in übersee
[Musik]
wir laden gehört ohne schlüssel hammer
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
einmal mehr muss beatrice den
vorbesitzer des modells um rat fragen
der gasherd springt nicht an
die amis haben das hotel samt inventar
gekauft vom gas anzünder über den herd
der betten bis hin zu den putzlappen und
auch den servier schützen alles wein
kaufpreis inbegriffen
[Musik]
jetzt werde ich es jetzt in betrieb
setzen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
kaum sind die ersten gäste versorgt
kommen schon weitere an
und doch es scheint dass es mit jedem
neuen gast besser geht
[Musik]
im industriegebiet von montevideo wie
sich rudi einen radlader kaufen mit dem
entsprechenden zubehör kann er diesen
als mehr gabelstapler und nicht zuletzt
als bagger einsetzen
alex heutige auftrag ist einmal mehr das
übersetzen ein wichtiger zusatz ist die
baggerschaufel mit entsprechendem arm
doch genau diese teile hat der verkäufer
nicht anlage ganz gott oder für mehr als
1000 dollar mit dem flugzeug her bringt
der aktion komplett
der verkäufer wie denn die will
schnellstmöglich abschließen und sucht
auf dem ganzen kontinent nach schaufel
und arm um wohl die bei laune zu halten
darf er eine erste runde mit dem
radlader fahren
[Musik]
schon bald hat der verkäufer neuigkeiten
den arm haben sie aber die schaufel
haben sie nicht jetzt müssen natürlich
auch am tag nach der schlüsselübergabe
beet an der nordsee eine steife brise
bevor den imbisswagen das neue logo
ziert muss die fassade gereinigt werden
der wagen selbst ist bereits aber
eigentlich noch frisch mit marianne ganz
toll gemacht
deswegen immer noch schlimmer noch halt
aber gehört im hof der softwarewartung
im april zur schlacht ist unser friede
trat er immer häufiger haben daher muss
auch fehler reicht denn der sommer hat
uns dieses jahr besetzen noch nicht
verwöhnt viele sagen wir hätten ja sturm
mir aber das ist doch kein sturm sturm
haben wir erst wenn die schafe keine
locken mehr haben das wäre das immer
schön da haben wir weil die bösen ganz
schön was hinterlassen aber wenn ich mal
eine möwe trifft das soll glück bringen
könnte es dann noch mal lotto spielen
aber ich glaube was aber mit wasser
nicht versickern mit dem binger und
damit dem alkohol
das alles
[Musik]
ein sprecher der bayerischen hypo- als
macher extra konto
für beide wäre damals wir kennen uns so
lange und so gut dass ich sicher bin
dass es nicht wirklich problem wirklich
[Musik]
kommt ja auch noch
etwas woran es in uruguay mangelt ist
fleisch während der baumaschinen
verkäufer in halb südamerika das
fehlende zubehör sucht essen ruhr die
und alex in einer typischen pariser zu
mittag mit oder ohne schaufel mit vollem
bauch geht es zurück zum verkäufer
[Musik]
und natürlich la pena besiegelte euro
unabdingbar tal der politik und bürger
also mehr demokratie google wird das
immer abgeschreckt teil und muss mit der
logan konnte maschine landete direkt in
der maschine kommen presse gelesen ja
ach so ja klar mit den anderen zubehör
sachen ganz vom rasenmähen und ich
anfallen
ich bin zu schwer
in der nächsten folge kommt zusammen
wobei an
sie muss vorläufig in einen
wohncontainer ziehen
er bekommt das ehepaar kunz hat die
perfekte wurst gefunden
große hektik am eröffnungstag hier und
ich die punkte
[Musik]
trotz hochsaison im velmoré-hotel wollen
die alba dass die gäste zimmer
renovieren und sie nehmen sich endlich
zeit für einen ausflug
die wiener
si
[Musik]
auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge